scp-049 is a fascinating bundle of
contradictions arguably he's the
hannibal lecter of the anomalous world
he's educated refined and cultured a
scientific man with scientific goals
capable of communicating eloquently in
both english and medieval french as
anomalies go he's one of the more
cooperative ones contained by the scp
foundation willing to understand reason
and even showing a small degree of
respect for his fellow researchers and
yet despite all this intelligence and
refinement underneath his dark organic
cloak a heart of deep red violence
steadily beats he's capable of ending
life with a mere touch causing all
biological functions in the body to
simply cease through means that are
still unknown to science thanks to a
series of inconclusive autopsies on
scp-049's unaltered victims not only is
killing easy in a physical sense for
scp-049 with a few notable exceptions
it's also been just as easy on his
conscience such is the danger of the man
or monster who believes unshakably that
his goals are righteous any moral crime
is permissible if done in service of
seeing them through and for those who
die at
scp-049's hand an even greater indignity
awaits his inhuman experiments the
gateway to a second life as an
abominable crime against nature a glob
of malignant spit in the eye of god but
let's not get too ahead of ourselves
here students we've mentioned scp-049
countless times in passing before some
of his strange tales his interactions
with other anomalies like
scp-682 and even with some of your
questions and theories about this
bone-masked scientific madman and yet he
still remains a mystery perhaps to truly
understand this fascinating walking
question we need to return to the
beginning and give the classified files
behind the plague doctor a closer look
like many of the infamous anomalies
discovered by the scp foundation the
files indicate that the discovery itself
was first triggered by a series of
mysterious disappearances in the sleepy
town of montabon out in southern france
people across races classes ages and
genders were simply falling off the map
suggesting a highly indiscriminate
assailant little did the foundation know
in the beady avian eyes of their killer
they all had an extremely important
commonality each and every one of them
was infected with the pestilence the
invisible scourge the great dying their
killer was the only one with the proper
diagnostic mind to even notice the
infection he was the only one who could
save the world from this insidious
unseen threat and then the scp
foundation discovered his laboratory the
plague doctor had been doing his
delicate work in an abandoned house on
the edge of town the kind of place that
gets whispered about in local rumors a
bad place a cursed place little did they
know it was only the latest in a long
line of covert research centers for this
singularly inspired medicine man while
some of the details were a little foggy
in his memory he'd been carrying out his
work for a little over 400 years now
moving from place to place causing
strings of disappearances wherever he
showed up in his own words he's an
extremely well-traveled man and still
the cure for the blasted pestilence
continued to evade him he sat in that
decrepit montabon house surrounded by
groaning writhing abominations of his
own creation taking meticulous notes
nothing would break his concentration
not even the strangers in the black
tactical gear with large guns kicking in
his front doors his many cured patients
didn't take kindly to the intrusion on
their treatment and decided to swarm the
interlopers what followed was a violent
struggle between the intruders and the
cured resulting in several of the
intruders injured and all of the cure
dead once more during all this chaos the
plague doctor never once stopped taking
notes when he was finished with his
sentence he willingly submitted to
capture by this mysterious scp
foundation after all when he told them
about the true nature of his mission
they would of course see reason and
allow him to continue his research sure
he may have committed a few crimes
against nature on the way but he was
working in service of loftier ideals you
can only imagine his profound relief
when he was first interviewed by scp
foundation researcher dr raymond hamm in
sight 85 he was in the presence of
fellow scholars people of science he
worried at first that he'd been captured
by some group of common street
scoundrels when in fact the hands of
providence had delivered him into the
perfect place to continue his research
the warm light of fate was now smiling
on him after so long languishing in the
dark all he needed to do was allow the
scientists around him to conduct tests
on his own body while he conducted tests
on others at first the scp foundation
believed he was an anomalous human being
wearing a costume but they soon
discovered that he was something very
different what they thought was a mask
was actually an outgrowth of his skull a
kind of insect-like exoskeleton the
robes were also a component of his body
a kind of thick hide that developed over
the years the thickness of the hide
itself also made him impervious to a
great deal of physical damage despite
his politeness research notes on the
plague doctor indicated that foundation
personnel found interacting with him
uncanny there was an oddly eerie quality
to him something indistinguishable that
just felt off the foundation also found
that the plague doctor whom they
initially addressed as doctor rather
than scp-049 out of a sense of mutual
respect also came with a number of
strange personal effects these included
a long pointing stick similar to the
ones used by medieval plague doctors to
touch things without fear of
contamination this stick was soon
confiscated it didn't possess any
anomalous qualities but the plague
doctor had a tendency to gesture
grantedly with it as he spoke and the
foundation feared he absentmindedly
takes someone's eye out with it if he
wasn't careful the other two personal
effects that the plague doctor prized
greatly was his old-fashioned medical
bag and the notebook that he obsessively
recorded his observations with the
medical bag which seemed to exhibit
anomalous properties contained a mix of
archaic medical tools as well as some
that the foundation has been unable to
identify it's through the tools in this
bag that the plague doctor is able to
create instances of scp-049-2
as we alluded to earlier the plague
doctor can kill with a touch but that's
only part of what he does to his victims
after causing all their biological
functions to cease he takes the tools
out of his medical bag and begins
performing crude surgery on their corpse
including using a syringe to inject an
unknown anomalous liquid into their
flesh while the specifics on the plague
doctor's modifications can vary from
victim to victim the result is often the
same they're converted into strange
shambling abominations that aren't
capable of any kind of higher thought
for the most part their movements are
extremely basic and limited however if
they're provoked they can become
frighteningly violent more than capable
of killing an armed foundation guard if
they don't remain alert during the
engagement the scp foundation was given
a unique opportunity to understand more
about
scp-049's twisted experiments as part of
his conditions for containment they
agreed to provide the diabolical doctor
with a number of fresh test subjects the
doctor was eager to continue his work
and through watching him work the scp
foundation could learn a great deal more
about him though we wouldn't even
pretend that the plague doctor's work
has ever been enjoyable to watch they
presented him with some live subjects
and a much greater number of mammalian
corpses he would spend several days
working intensely on each one then
documenting his findings in his precious
notebook as a mark of respect for the
foundation scientists around him the
plague doctor was more than eager to
share his research with them and compare
notes he was always a talkative one
perhaps just as excited to discuss his
experiments and theories with
like-minded scholars after so many years
of working alone here are four notable
instances first the plague doctor was
presented with a live d-class specimen
he thanked the foundation greatly for
this gift then set about his work he
asked the unaware d-class several
questions about his medical history
while retrieving tools from his bag
before quickly touching and killing the
man he performed extensive modifications
on the d-class corpse and when he was
resurrected as an scp-049-2
instance he was barely recognizable as
his original form he was a bizarre
flailing creature constantly groaning
and gasping from the oblong-shaped hole
that the plague doctor had carved into
his chest while performing this
horrifying work the plague doctor
eagerly remarked to the observing
researchers that the cure appears to be
extremely effective next he was provided
the corpse of a recently deceased goat
which he also expressed gratitude for
after performing surgery on the creature
it was successfully resurrected into a
bizarre scp-049-2
instance however the plague doctor
readily admitted that this definitely
wasn't his best work commenting the
disease was still in its nascent stage
my veterinary practice is rudimentary
but the patient responded well to the
procedure
next he was provided the corpse of a
recently deceased orangutan the plague
doctor was delighted by this commenting
that given primate similarities to human
physiology this would be the next best
thing from a true human test subject
however this research became
surprisingly fraught he killed and
reanimated the beast four different
times seemingly unsatisfied with the
result each time and when he failed to
reanimate the creature a fifth time he
seemed disconcerted in a debriefing
discussion the plague doctor said i have
learned so much from this though i fear
my early optimism was misplaced i hadn't
yet come across such a
a stumbling block on my road to the cure
more subjects like this would do a great
deal in advancing my research next it
was provided with the corpse of a
recently deceased cow this irritated
scp-049 who wanted test subjects who
were physiologically closer to humans
still despite his frustration he
continued to work he took only brief
breaks to enjoy a meal of hard cheese
salted pork and thin crackers tests
showed that scp-049 didn't require
sustenance to survive but he enjoyed the
act of eating and found that it helped
him with his work he embalmed the cow
rearranging its organs and even inverted
its head however this didn't impede his
work he injected it with a variety of
liquids which he described as the
essence of the humors when asked to
elaborate further on this he said the
pestilence may bring about a systemic
imbalance in such a case before true
healing can begin one must find the
humors in balance or the body will
reject the cure this is of course
elementary knowledge for the practical
physician i would have thought to have
learned this during your education after
being provided a working cattle prod to
induce a little electricity into the
equation the plague doctor successfully
reanimated the mutant cow from here
things started to go downhill dr ham
decided to conduct another interview
with scp-049
hoping to get into the finer details of
his scientific process however they hid
some major roadblocks scp-049
seemed to be unable to actually
articulate the true nature of the
pestilence or his process in seeking the
cure even his notebook wasn't written in
any known language and proved impossible
to decipher as the interview went on the
plague doctor seemed to become
increasingly distressed
insisting on the importance of his work
to helping the human race prosper and
survive this terrible plague all he
needed in exchange was more test
subjects the practice civility that had
been built up between the plague doctor
and the scp foundation crumbled in 2017
after a tragic incident in the plague
doctor's cell with dr ham when he
entered to perform a very standard
interview with the plague doctor the
doctor appeared to become anxious and
asked dr hamm if he was feeling well
today dr ham thought nothing of it and
tried to continue the interview but by
that point it was already too late the
plague doctor had come to believe that
dr ham was infected with the pestilence
and of course there was only one cure
the plague doctor gave dr ham his touch
of death the man died instantly and the
plague doctor immediately went about
turning his corpse into another
scp-049-2
instance because ham was killed so
quickly he didn't have time to activate
his emergency security signal meaning
what was left of him wasn't discovered
until three hours later guards and
researchers were horrified to see one of
their own turned into a mindless
deformed monster by an anomaly they all
thought they could trust following this
tragic incident dr theoren sherman
chastised the plague doctor for this
appalling breach of trust and the
cold-blooded murder of dr raymond hamm
the plague doctor in a state of
increasing distress insisted that ham
was infected and he did all that he
could to cure him and while the plague
doctor insisted a certain level of
scientific distance from his subject it
seemed that deep down he regretted the
loss of a friend and fellow researcher
in his endless quest against the
pestilence after this incident the
plague doctor truly became scp-049
he lost all of his privileges and now
remains under lock and key in sight 19.
whenever he's transported he's kept in
shackles and supervised by a number of
armed guards after discovering that the
scent of lavender has a pacifying effect
on him it's regularly used as a
tranquilizer against him during
engagements this is how a cordial ally
can become just another prisoner in the
eyes of the scp foundation in a summary
interview after the dr ham incident dr
elijah itkin asked if 049 had any
regrets about the incident noting that
he seemed oddly mournful zero four nine
pause before replying mon perhaps i had
not thought that it is lamentable that a
fellow doctor became infected but the
work continues regrettable as
as it was dr ham's death provided
important insight living human subjects
are the only way to proceed forward i'm
decided my cure is of little use on dead
flesh and i have cleaned all i can from
your generous supply of corpses my
desires turn towards tending to those
still living who suffer from the disease
dr itkin replied that 049 would be
disappointed on that front he just
laughed in response and replied
oh doctor i wouldn't be so sure
now go check out scp-049 what actually
is the pestilence the plague doctor
questions and theories and
scp-049 going home for more on the
enigmatic plague doctor scp-049